[Musique]
pourquoi je suis en olive et tom
aujourd'hui parce que il ya plusieurs
sujets bien sûr il ya le nouvel album de
maître gims mais il est venu aussi avec
son frère je vous demande d'applaudir
darcis est avec lille alors vous êtes
lancés dans le manga et c'est très très
réussie
franchement je le dis tous les
spécialistes qui ont lu le truc disent
que c'est très réussi les critiques sont
très bonne on a kiffé je vous le dis on
attise et de se mettre tous en manga
alors moi je suis le plus pourri
jolimont millon d'olive et tom on
comprend pas on va accueillir tout de
suite jeanne et serge c'est parti merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle
j'avais dit que j'étais le plus pourri
je vais vous lire on va maintenant
accueillir est ce que vous connaissez
ken scène mais il est avec nous ken le
survivant
vous allez voir la fenêtre chez nous
alors vous voyez ken le survivant c'est
ça oui la mémoire chez le ken le
survivant
on dirait un acteur de films x
[Musique]
j'ai déconné votre famille vous regarde
malheureusement quand une cigogne drac
c'est ça alors goldorak chez nous le
costume est arrivé tard à coeur tout de
suite albator
voilà
je préfère
c'est les chevaliers du zodiaque mais
ils ont pris un coup dans la gueule non
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mamie je crois que tu es bourré et on
refait son entrée en campagne avec on a
sailor moon a laissé partir d'indicés
lors
[Musique]
l'habitat là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a
ces pokémon terre
[Applaudissements]
nicky larson
on est obligé de recevoir sangoku et
dragon ball z
[Applaudissements]
dans quel épisode on a vu dragon ball z
16 heures là non tiens c'est quoi
l'argonne éviter ou non mais sans
rigoler dragonball franck de vita
m
[Musique]